The right loves to say that the left is waging
a culture war rather than an issues based
war.
But I am going to make the case today that
it is effectively the Donald Trump administration
that is actually doing that.
The last 12 hours on Twitter for Donald Trump
have been very, very wacky.
He will not or cannot stop lying.
He seemed to defend the Confederate flag.
He tweeted more racism, including referring
to Indian Elizabeth Warren.
And the context of all of this is Trump's
approval is down to 38 percent.
Trump is losing by an average of seven in
Michigan, losing by six in Wisconsin and Pennsylvania
losing by five, and Florida losing by three
in Arizona.
And he's just falling apart visibly, publicly
and embarrassingly.
And we're going to go through just a couple
of these elements and then circle back to
the culture war component.
Trump continued his empirically demonstrable
lies related to Corona virus, which is, of
course, spreading.
As I told you yesterday, we are seeing pretty
dramatic approval cratering for Trump in the
most affected counties by Corona virus.
Trump tweeting, quote, Why does the lame stream
fake news media refuse to say that China virus
deaths are down thirty nine percent and that
we now have the lowest fatality mortality
rate in the world?
They just can't stand that.
We are doing so well for our capital C country.
Now, this is just not true about the mortality
rate.
We have the ninth highest per capita death
rate in the world.
Out of more than 200 countries and territories,
ninth highest.
If you don't include tiny countries like San
Marino and Andorra, the U.S. has the seventh
highest per capita death rate in the world.
So Trump is lying.
Now, in terms of the decrease in deaths, I'm
glad we've seen a trending down in deaths.
There's a bunch of possibilities still on
the table.
The deaths haven't happened because of a lag
time.
They would start this week, presumably.
We already saw yesterday Texas tie their record
high for single day deaths.
Could be a less deadly strain.
That's a possibility, although we don't actually
have evidence for that yet.
There could be states that are lying about
the death toll.
Could be younger folks lately.
Getting the virus who are less likely to die
could mean that more testing is leading to
more tests for people who are less sick, which
is going to reduce that comparative death
rate.
We just don't know yet.
But what we are seeing, at least in Texas,
is that those death numbers are starting to
go up.
Then Trump moved on to talking about Elizabeth
Warren.
Donald Trump, of course, focusing lately on
statues and sports team names, tweeting, quote,
They name teams out of strength, not weakness.
But now the Washington Redskins and Cleveland
Indians, two fabled sports franchises look
like they are going to be changing their names
in order to be politically correct.
Indians like Elizabeth Warren must be very
angry right now.
I'm not even going to insult your intelligence
by doing an analysis of that one.
I think you all get the wackiness of that
one.
And then on to the Confederate flag, tweeting,
quote, Has Bubba Wallace apologize to all
of those great NASCAR drivers and officials
who came to his aid, stood by his side and
were willing to sacrifice everything for him,
only to find out that the whole thing was
just another hoax.
That and flag decision has cost lowest ratings
ever.
So what Trump is referring to there is that
NASCAR made a decision that the Confederate
flag would not be allowed at their events.
It won't be allowed in the crowd.
It won't be allowed on cars or in team areas
or whatever Trump says.
That is why ratings are down for NASCAR.
So question one is where people really tuning
into NASCAR for the Confederate flag, because
if so, that would be really weird.
But next, what I want to get to is that when
this came up during Kaley McKenzies press
briefing yesterday, again, a really bad day
for Trump once again.
Reportedly, Trump is watching more TV than
ever and is in his own world.
Kaili McEnany refused to even say whether
Trump is indeed saying he supports the Confederate
flag here or not.
And that's what I want to talk about next.